where did you go squirrel
on the ground
[Music]
I miss you
so much
and maybe
maybe if you open yourself up to it
there's a possibility I don't think so
Quinn
quill quill
I don't think so
but what I'm trying to say Peter you
know this is an open line right what
we're listening to everything you're
saying and it is painful and you're just
telling me now we were hoping I would
stop on its own but I switched it over
to private what color button did you
push blue for the blue suit oh no blue
was the Open Line for everyone orange is
for blue what black is for orange yellow
is for green green is for red and red is
for yellow no yellow is for yellow green
is for red red is for green I don't
think so try it then
hello
you're right
I'm so sorry about this Yoda oh please
we're here to save the life of our
friend that is all
we paid her to help us get in and get
out you think that mean oh I'm gonna
help you do it in a way that no one
knows it's happening but no what she
means is I'm gonna shoot people threaten
people's lives
and I know you're probably asking why
would I trust her well that's a good
question
the answer is
we used to be in love yeah she was my
girlfriend only she doesn't remember it
because it wasn't her because her dad
threw off a magic clip and she died and
then I lost my temper and nearly
destroyed half the universe
and she came back out of the past there
she is
everyone else who died in the past
stayed dead not her why was it the magic
Cliff I don't know that's some freaking
infinity stone scientist
and some dumbass Earth dude who met a
girl fell in love
that girl died
and then came back a total dick
that is the gist of it
Drax stay here with rocket watch him
that's who they're coming for I want to
come no mantis watch Drax Groot
you know what to do with these
push down on it
push it down Yoshi down on it push the
button
it looks like you're pushing the keyhole
the what there's a button under the
handle
press that in
okay now what open the door
that is a stupid design and your
instructions were very unclear
yo friend wants took advantage
I learned my lessons
I aimed some small parts of my mental
capacity back in my own Direction and
now gravity itself serves my whims you
must find counter Earth familiar counter
Earth I visited your planet many years
ago Earth hasn't been my planet in a
long time you know people had
wonderful spirit the art and music and
literature were some of the finests in
the universe
Earth would be a fabulous place for it
not for the ignorance and bigotry okay
it inspired me to create counter-ups I
don't care all of the good and none of
the bad I don't need another speech by
some impotent whack job whose mother
didn't love him rationalizing why he
needs to conquer the universe I'm not
trying to conquer the universe
I'm perfecting it